oggi parlamento delle città del futuro e
all'immagine derby e come noi e di
cultura laica dell'odierna portando
laziale è sempre stata proprio per il
suo perde per la presenza delle acque
del terreno parte compensata dallo
storico
che possiamo vedere il villaggio delle
macchine un abitato dell'età del bronzo
oggi quasi completamente completamente
ricoperta delle acque del lago albano
chiamata così per la presenza di un
centinaio di mancina cinesi in pietra
vulcanica
la bellezza e l'importanza di questa
zona ci viene tramandata anche
attraverso le leggende che spesso
trovano riscontro nelle testimonianze
archeologiche
probabilmente dell'azione dei bus e
della mitica albalonga
fondata da a scario figlio di elea e ora
troiano enea e rame
rappresentato bene sempre rappresentato
come
obbediente agli dèi molto coraggioso
secondo me che lanci un uomo di cultura
se non per altro dei tanti viaggi che
fece succede pure negli inferi e
lievitati di al bando possono vantarsi
di questa discendenza alba longa maggior
cento oltre agli abitati dei popoli
latini il capoluogo politico e religioso
di carta alle spalle della moderna mano
sul giro del lago albano ai piedi del
monte albano per uno
scatolo a giove age laziale oggi
montecarlo
io personalmente ho visto sempre al bano
come una capitale mancata ne aveva tutti
i presupposti
però le cose andarono diversamente
non possiamo parlare da citare la
propria quando parlano di alba longa
grosse perché ci provo
umana però se vogliamo credere stampo
romano tito livio albalonga città in
città quando fu fondata a roma a
esisteva già da 400 anni cos'è andato
diversamente nel famoso duello trovarsi
con le app su la testa tra gli albani e
i romani di vita una guerra fratricida
insieme romani
qui possiamo vedere in volto con questo
poco dentro degli orazi e curiazi che in
realtà sappiamo bene il mondo è perché
la battaglia
succede nel vii secolo avanti cristo
invece questa tombe del primo secolo
avanti cristo
poi poco dopo questo famoso duello
albalonga fini tuta completamente dal
terzo rinvio nome ad uno stile sempre
nel vii secolo avanti cristo e dello
stile un re delittuoso
però speciale un saggio rispettino i
tempi li ha nuovamente la specie per la
paura degli dei non voleva essere
illuminato da giove proprio perché oggi
interpretando liberamente
e pensare che anche questo è potere
ultimamente non era un uomo di cultura
ha capito l'importanza dei beni
culturali e della loro conservazione e
la cosa che spesso non capita oggi
tutti gli albani con tastiere i figli a
roma su come cerio però non dimenticarlo
le loro origini e comunque monte albano
mite cavo rimase un tocco di culto molto
importante dove nel salvario riceve
laziale venivano celebrate le prime
latine ogni anno che comprendevano
sacrificio di tutore bianco equitani poi
venivano divise tra i partecipanti ai
rappresentanti dei popoli erbani proprio
verso terminali sottolineare questa
comune precedenza da dai ne ha
poi
la storia comunque di questo territorio
finisce qui
abbiamo la
costruzione di altri all'aviaria fatto
secolo avanti cristo poi il bambino è
sempre un dono sacco pieno di mostri
sacri po di culto santuari molto
frequentato dai fedeli oggi diremmo
turismo religioso le specialità di
investitori non veniva solo dalla
presenza delle idee
degli altari diciamo degli attuali ma
anche della conservazione della natura
nella corda studiare ea secoli dopo
goethe nel suo viaggio in italia
parlando appunto dei colli albani nelle
repubblicana ancora una volta grazie al
verde abbiamo ragazzi a bere dal prima
mita il prodotto dal piano gastronomici
andando sempre termini di oggi e anche
grazie alla vicinanza di roma sono state
costruite molte ville la vita di pompeo
magno la vita ai palazzi sia ville di
residenza che ville rustiche ad uso
agricolo
durante questo periodo la classe ha
visto cantano tutti sicuramente arrivano
ad un modello di vita
incentrato sull'impegno intellettuale
conseguenza del cambio del contatto con
la realtà grete e allora questi bossi
miss piggy di queste ville e l'amante da
un idiozia filosofia di cultura in
generale arriviamo
agli imperatori romani
diversi di loro soggiornavano qui
dobbiamo doveva dominare domiziano di
questo vita sua immensa villa proprio
fan che si estendeva the castel gandolfo
ad alba secondo alcuni studiosi occupato
i tuoi 600 ettari e poi vediamo la
chiesa di santa maria hoe tonda che però
ufficialmente consegnate non dice del
secolo però sorge su
chi piace la propria parte della di
questa vita di domiziano cento va avanti
il lago di albano
che l'imperatore in ogni modo
che ad angela maggior fama ad albano
sicuramente settimio severo che con il
202 ho visto la seconda del genere
patica proprio qui ad albano alle porte
di roma
e questa seconda legione partica
superata se però la carta e scontate
consistente alla signoria dove ha
combattuto
contro dei parchi le funzioni di questa
regione
la difesa dell'imperatore la difesa di
roma anche una specie di una squadra
reparto mobile che seguiva l'imperatore
le sue battaglie le tre gioni questo è
molto importante le di genere questo mi
state mille miglia lungo i confini
invece questa regione era situata
proprio alle porte di roma era presente
un tal in europa un'altra azione anche
oggi per i turisti
e poi se vivessero dell'umidità un
condottiero programmino un politico
ma io come la vita degli regionali poi
anche gli accampamenti divenne un po di
design di cultura allora in cordate
interne ridotte a quella moglie di
settimio severo giulia donna proveniente
dalla siria era una persona che lei di
cultura
il leoncino adesso pubblicazione solo
secondo dalla degenerata e capisce che
lei si interessava di politica della
regione e letteratura filosofia mi
creando intorno a sé una sorta di scena
o salotto del diario hunter quelli va
dei migliori menti del suo tempo
devo dire un attimo che durante
l'età di sederi all'impero
chiamato il tema e per commenti per gli
ufficiali della seconda delle parti che
poi vediamo
che la vita va bene costruito per il
diletto delle generali della loro
famiglie e poi i cisternoni che sono
sicuramente in un mezzo più suggestivo
del
vano la cisterna in telecom in attacco
la quinta dell'accampamento
alimentate da pedotti ed è ancora in uso
ancora oggi
poi possiamo
sono stati ovviamente anche i legionari
parti c è diffondere bestià nismo alla
religione e in albano che poi divenne
sede vescovile
una delle tante testimonianze della
presenza del cristianesimo sono le
catacombe di san senatore crediamo fa un
altro dato che dimostra l'importanza di
albano e che nel fatto che l'inverno e
questo motivo costruì una basilica dal
bagno onori concesso solo a roma napoli
cup ostia e appunto ad albano come devo
la cattedrale che abbiamo affrontata da
quella dedica costanziana
dedicate modificate diverse cose però
probabilmente questa cattedrale
costruita su diciamo sulle basi per i
resti dell'antica basilica del iv secolo
diciamo che nel medioevo la città
dominata dalla cabina saverio poi entrò
a far parte dello stato pontificio e
comunque quello che voglio sottolineare
è dicendo sempre po sul luogo di cultura
persone di cultura che albano che questa
città nei secoli passati è stata sempre
un luogo di cultura per ricordare anche
che non l'ho già detto che gli altri di
studio dell'intellettuale prima europei
che americani nell'ambito del quale del
quale molti personaggi illustri
visitarono urbano alcuni lo abitano e
lavorano diciamo perché
contest ieri parlando dell'area dei
castelli romani dice che da pienza a
roma da roma a napoli non ha visto
giorni migliori e più vita della gita in
costruiti strade chiese ben fatte delle
strade come contrada assai fortuna
stesse ed è veramente un compimento
rispettate visto che viene da un
pensatore libero stesso molto critico
dei concordi dell'italia perfetta invece
ha scritto una visibilità che sentito da
come visitare roma 10 josie dell'ultimo
giorno hai vinto il pd modo che include
al ballo e questa è solo una di tante
tante guide del periodo del cantù che
descrivono questa città dell'altra stato
dubbioso il passato è molto importante
una frase fatta da chi si interessa del
termine mai tre stanze di legge le scale
studiare per cui piace a prescindere
passato nascono le idee per il futuro e
rende benissimo l'idea un passo di
andrea
carandini del suo libro il primo giorno
dove dice della stratificazione un padre
archiviata sotto i nostri piedi un
flusso di dati sono impotenza che
prendono significato e vado mica
soltanto
nel racconto accesi dalle domande del
nostro tempo ho menzionato più volte no
ma ci sta benissimo con cui non possiamo
non ci possiamo perdonare non abbiamo la
sistina del pugile riposo nella finalina
molti recente trovate nel territorio di
albano
poi si trovano ci piacciono dei romani
ma dobbiamo dire che con quello che è
rimasta è stato fatto un ottimo lavoro
esiste un bel cesto monumentale tante
iniziative culturali e di storia che ci
sono qui come per esempio la regione
sistemata alle porte di roma poi fondare
su tutto ricomposto edilizia la cosa
bella di pd vestite che si possono
visitare a piedi però arriviamo ai
problemi della viabilità e ecco dal palo
del futuro meno macchine delle idee
diciamo che cambiare proprio il modo di
pensare di vedere i mezzi pubblici con
una positiva i treni come fosse di
cultura forse capirete rari
assolutamente una cosa futuristica però
un'altra ed è verde per senso è un
consiglio neanche un progetto di tre
bambini nei musei però non bambini delle
elementari e medi che già i progetti ci
sono ma proprio i neonati di 23 anni che
si abituano diciamo alla cultura e ad
una cosa di gara dopo
ecco vorrei concludere con una citazione
di
tenuta a roma
dice doma metà dell'ottocento e mi è
piaciuta però e dintorni di roma si vive
ad alba ma a piedi con gli amici e nasce
la mamma dice finalmente si respira più
diaria
mi auguro che questo possa essere una
specie di manifesto per alfano per la
barra del futuro e chiunque si trovi
residente o turista possa dire
finalmente si respira un po più piano
sia letteralmente yara